>>> HERE WE ARE.
THERE'S AN ENTIRE CLOSET FULL
OF --
>> SECRET CLOSET.
>> OF HASHTAG WOKE T-SHIRTS.
>> THAT WAS TWITTER'S NEW OWNER
ELON MUSK MOCKING A T-SHIRT THE
COMPANY MADE YEAR AGO TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR BLACK EMPLOYEES AND
USERS.
JACK DORSEY WORE THE SHIRT IN A
PANEL.
SOME CRITICS CRITICIZED FOR HIM
WEARING IT.
HE MENTIONED BEING ON THE GROUND
IN FERGUSON OVER THE SHOOTING OF
BROWN.
ELON MUSK THEN ERASED THE POST.
MUSK REPLACED THE DELETED TWEET
WITH A FOLLOW-UP LINK CONTAINING
A LINK TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE REPORT ON BROWN'S DEATH.
MUSK SAID THAT HANDS UP DON'T
SHOOT WAS MADE UP, THE WHOLE
THING WAS A FICTION.
THIS NEEDS SOME CONTEXT.
>> HANDS UP --
>> DON'T SHOOT.
>> SO THE PHRASE HANDS UP, DON'T
SHOOT BECAME A NATIONAL RALLYING
CRY IN 2014 IN SOLIDARITY WITH
MICHAEL BROWN, THE TEENAGER WHO
SOME SAID HAD HIS HANDS UP IN
SURRENDER WHEN HE WAS SHOT BY
DARIN WILSON.
IT WAS CONCLUDED IN THE REPORT
THAT BROWN WAS SHOT WHEN HE WAS
MOVING TOWARDS THE OFFICER.
THIS IS WHAT MUSK REFERENCED IN
THE TWEETS.
THE DOJ DID NOT FIND GROUNDS TO
CHARGE THE OFFICER BUT IT DID
FIND EVIDENCE OF RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION IN FERGUSON AT
THE HANDS OF THE CITY'S POLICE
DEPARTMENT AND MUNICIPAL COURT.
THE DOJ IN ITS REPORT POINTED TO
THE STATISTICS FOR PROOF.
BLACK PEOPLE IN FERGUSON ARE
TWICE AS LIKELY TO BE SEARCHED
IN VEHICLE STOPS THAN WHITES.
THOUGH WHITES WERE FOUND TO HAVE
CONTRABAND AT A HIGHER RATE.
AT LEAST 85% OF THOSE PULLED
OVER OR TICKETED WERE BLACK AND
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT SAID IT
WAS MONEY NOT PUBLIC SAFETY THAT
THE DEPARTMENT FOCUSED ON.
AND BLACK CITIZENS PAID THE
HIGHEST PRICE.
SO REMEMBER, HANDS UP DON'T
SHOOT BECAME A NATIONWIDE
SYMBOL.
IT WAS ABOUT THE PATTERN OF
POLICE SHOOTINGS AND BRUTALITY
IN THIS COUNTRY AND HASHTAG STAY
WOKE, WHICH MUSK MOCKED, WAS HOW
TWITTER WANTED CALLED OUT
RACIAL -- HOW THEY WANTED TO
CALL OUT RACIAL INJUSTICE.
TESLA'S MARKET VALUE HAS TAKEN A
HUGE HIT THIS YEAR AUND THIS
TIME A YEAR AGO THE COMPANY'S
VALUE WAS AROUND $1.2 TRILLION.
BY THE END OF THE DAY YESTERDAY,
IT SAT AT $580 BILLION.
THOSE NUMBERS ARE FROM FORBES
AND DO THE MATH THAT'S MORE THAN
A $600 BILLION DECLINE.
TO PUT THIS LOSS IN PERSPECTIVE.
IT'S NOT A PAPER LOSS, THE SHARE
PRICE HERE.
DISNEY IS WORTH ABOUT
$180 BILLION, NIKE $167 BILLION,
STARBUCKS $114 BILLION.
LET'S BRING IN PETER SHANKMAN, A
FUTURIST AT BLUE SHARK DIGITAL.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU HERE.
I DON'T KNOW HOW I GOT THROUGH
THE INTROWITHOUT SAYING ELON
MUSK.
>> SHOULDN'T ELON MUSK BE PAYING
ATTENTION TO TESLA.
>> I'M TRYING TO RUN ONE COMPANY
ON MY OWN, HE'S RUNNING FOUR.
IF YOU ARE SPENDING YOUR TIME
CREATING MEMES AND ARGUING WITH
POLITICIANS PUBLICALLY YOU'RE
NOT RUNNING YOUR BUSINESS.
FROM TESLA'S STANDPOINT IF I WAS
A SHAREHOLDER.
>> THE SHAREHOLDERS HAD HIM ON
THE STAND IN A TRIAL LAST WEEK
BECAUSE THEY'RE MAD.
>> IT'S HARD TO PROVE HE'S NOT
WORKING FOR TESLA.
BUT THEY CAN SAY YOU STOLE
ENGINEERS FROM TESLA TO BRING
THEM TO TWITTER.
THAT'S A PROBLEM.
TESLA IS OVERVALUED, BEEN
OVERVALUED FOR A LONG TIME, NO
QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
BUT IF HE WAS SMART HE'D SAY
IT'S OVERVALUED, LET ME BE QUIET
FOR A WHILE.
HE'S NOT DOING THAT.
HE'S DOING EVERYTHING POSSIBLE
TO DRAW MORE ATTENTION TO
HIMSELF.
>> WHAT WAS YOUR ANALOGY WHEN WE
TALKED ABOUT IT IN THE BREAK.
>> I HAVE A DOG, WAFFLE, TWO
YEARS OLD.
EVERY TIME HE DOES SOMETHING
STUPID, STEALS A STEAK OFF THE
TABLE.
HE EATS IT AND LOOKS AT ME.
WHO STOLE THE STEAK?
HELLO.
IF HE DIDN'T LOOK ATTENTION TO
ME, MAYBE I WOULDN'T PAY
ATTENTION TO IT AND MOVE ON.
SAME WITH TESLA.
HE'S NOT GIVING ANYONE A CHANCE
TO FORGET ABOUT HIM.
>> WHAT'S WITH THIS THESE GUYS?
THEY CAN'T HELP THEMSELVES --
>> THEY'VE NEVER BEEN TOLD NO.
THEY SURROUND THEMSELVES WITH
PEOPLE WHO HAVE ALWAYS YESSED
THEM.
SO NOW PEOPLE ARE ARGUING WITH
HIM, MAKING A FOOL OF HIM.
HE'S THE NUMBER ONE JOKE ON
REDDIT RIGHT NOW.
SO HE SAYS LET ME BUY TWITTER
AND I CAN HAVE MY PLATFORM TO
SAY WHAT I WANT.
AND THIS IS AFFECTING HIS OTHER
BUSINESSES.
>> AND ALSO $44 BILLION NOT AS
RICH.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
IT ADDS UP TO REAL MONEY.
>> I'M HESITANT TO UNDERESTIMATE
ELON MUSK BECAUSE OF WHAT HE HAS
DONE.
SO WE'LL SEE.
BUT RIGHT NOW IT DOESN'T LOOK
GOOD.
HOWEVER AN INTERESTING POINT
ABOUT THAT, $44 BILLION IT
WASN'T HIS MONEY.
THERE ARE A LOT OF LENDERS.
AS I UNDERSTAND IT, THE DEBT TO
FINANCE THIS IS BACKED UP BY
TESLA, SO TESLA COULD TAKE A
BIGGER HIT IF THIS GOES UNDER.
>> HIS SHARES IN TESLA.
HE'S ALREADY SOLD AN ADDITIONAL
3 BILLION, THERE'S MORE COMING.
WHEN EVERYTHING IS LINKED THAT
CLOSELY.
I WOULDN'T WANT TO INVEST IN
SOMETHING LINKED THAT CLOSELY TO
OTHER THINGS AND HIM NOT BEING
QUIET BECAUSE IT STOPS BEING
ABOUT THE COMPANY AND STARTS
BEING HIM.
YOU CAN'T HAVE A GOOD COMPANY
WHEN IT'S ONLY ONE PERSON,